la decisión se ha tomado por unanimidad
tal como ocurrió en la víspera en la
duma Este martes los miembros del senado
ratificaron la incorporación de las
autoproclamadas republicas de doniach y
logans y las provincias de gersor como
parte de la federación rusa los
territorios anexados unilateralmente por
el kremlin suponen cerca del 18% del
territorio reconocido internacionalmente
a Ucrania en paralelo Moscú sigue
entrenando a miles de soldados para
llevarlos al frente de batalla tras su
llamado a la movilización parcial de
hace dos semanas
al día de hoy más de 200.000 personas se
han incorporado a las fuerzas armadas he
ordenado que se les proporcione a todos
ellos uniformes y otros equipos
necesarios y se les nombra en puestos
militares el personal de servicio debe
ser enviada a las zonas de combate
después del fin del entrenamiento y el
ensayo
en el terreno la arremetida continúa
desde Ucrania temen que los ataques del
ejército ruso contra infraestructuras
estratégicas puedan redoblarse con la
llegada del Invierno
no obstante en kiev siguen reivindicando
sus avances en el sur y el oeste
liberando según las autoridades varias
localidades a las orillas del río nipron
Los logros militares los reflejan estos
soldados ucranianos izando banderas en
pueblos de jarqui y gerson
hay nuevos asentamientos liberados en
varias regiones continúan los combates
feroces en muchas áreas del frente pero
la perspectiva de estas hostilidades
sigue siendo obvia cada vez más
ocupantes están tratando de escapar el
ejército enemigo está sufriendo más y
más bajas y hay una comprensión
creciente de que Rusia cometió un error
al ir a la guerra contra Ucrania pese a
los llamados de nuevas sanciones
internacionales
Moscú sigue escalando su ofensiva dentro
y fuera de u